hi guys I'm Eric Voss and Avengers 4
released a synopsis for the film with
some choice words that could actually
confirm some of the boldest theories
that we've been discussing for the movie
Marvel was willing to go full comic book
nerd when they killed off half the
Avengers and infinity war could they
really out Nerdist again Avengers board
sounds like they will let's break it all
down and a yeah spoiler warning in case
we end up being too right okay here's
what we're talking about on Amazon a
book just went on presale called the
road to Marvel's Avengers for the arts
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe comes
out on May 7th a few days after Avengers
4 comes out now this book will contain
interviews with cast and crew and set
photos and concept art that the movies
creative teams used to inspire their
visuals in all these movies Marvel
actually did a similar book released
last year with the road to Marvel's
Avengers infinity war release
coordinated with the infinity war films
release now what is interesting is the
synopsis that Marvel listed for this new
book which includes this line the fourth
installment the Avengers saga will be
the culmination of 22 interconnected
films and we'll let audiences witness
the turning point of this epic journey
now for those of us who have been
obsessing over Avengers forward news
with tweet downs and toy downs really
going down with whatever we have to
this synopsis sounds familiar it
actually was the exact wording from a
synopsis for Avengers 4 that was written
in licensed global magazine about a
month after Infinity Ward came out we
didn't pay it much attention then
because you know it was in May and all
kinds of Avengers related headlines were
coming out around then you can't listen
all of them but the fact that this exact
sentence was repeated gives it a little
more weight on the old legitness scale
and that previous synopsis included an
additional sentence it described of
interest forward this way blah blah blah
witness a turning point of this epic
journey our beloved heroes will truly
understand how fragile this reality is
and the sacrifices that must be made to
uphold it Wow ok remember to breathe
let's take this key phrase my key phrase
first off turning point the phrase that
showed up both from the old synopsis and
this new one I don't think it's too big
of a bombshell like we've always known
that Avengers 4 would be the final film
of Marvel Studios phase 3 and really the
way these movies are structured you
could argue that each one of them is a
turning point of sorts they're all epic
they're all game changers hell even the
quirky grounded Side Story of ant-man
introduced the quantum realm to us which
is potentially the
easiest cosmic element that we've seen
so far in them see you but the second
key phrase I want to point out our
beloved ears will truly understand how
fragile this reality is this reality yes
I have eaten up a lot of airtime
screaming to you about all the clues and
hints that Avengers 4 could delve into
time travel I still think that's
possible but more and more than I think
about it if I had to make a prediction
here I think it's more likely that the
way the Avengers will defeat Thanos
would be crossing over into parallel
realities and just explain the
difference there time-travel suggest
moving back to past moments within our
current timeline to change them either
causing a ripple effect of future points
on that timeline or a new timeline to
split off and diverge from it by
comparison multiple realities is really
me moving back and forth linearly within
the timeline but rather horizontally
across multiple timelines it's also
referred to as the multiverse and it
posits that this universe exists
alongside a series of independent
parallel dimensions this concept is
something that we have seen explored
before on shows like Rick and Morty
sliders and the final season of lost
stranger things - I think we don't
really know what the upside-down is as
well as movies like coherence and yeah
the Marvel Comics the DC Comics and the
world of Stephen King multiverses are
everywhere in media the creators of Rick
and Morty specifically structured their
science-fiction adventures on a
multiverse instead of time-travel
because they felt that time-travel had
been overused as the premise and they
want to open themselves up to more
freewheeling stories and while the
Marvel comics have these time-travel as
a plot device several times the x-men
are very guilty of that the idea of
multiple parallel realities allowed the
comics to be more creatively daring for
example rather than just one spider-man
who can only face one Green Goblin in
his lifetime why not have hundreds of
different Spider men and women in
different realities and face all kinds
of villains Sony's upcoming spider-man
into the spider versus throwing all
these doppelgangers together in one
story that looks really fun and with
audiences becoming more and more
accustomed to multiple realities as a
fantasy trope Avengers 4 could finally
stretch general audiences imaginations
far enough to the level of weirdness
that really exists in the comic books
every day and within this Marvel
Cinematic Universe it wouldn't be
totally out of left field recently an
ant-man the wasp Bill Foster's lecture
on quantum physics included this line in
other words the object in question would
be both in and out of phase with
multiple parallel
realities so what could this look like
in Avengers 4 well one way they could do
this is maybe Scott Lang being stranded
in the quantum realm could lead to his
discovery of a way to cross into one of
these parallel realities a reality in
which history played out a little
differently hell maybe even a different
parallel reality for each of the
20-something heroes in these movies the
reality in which each of them are the
most badass self like that could explain
why we've seen set photos of Hawkeye
with a look closer to the Hawkeye Ronin
character in the comics maybe there's a
separate reality where he's a loner
assassin that Tony Stark and Scott Lang
can recruit Clint from like cool we got
the best Hawkeye check a multiverse
could explain why we've heard rumors
about frank grillo crossbones
reappearing in the series like maybe
there's reality where he didn't blow
himself up an explosion at Scarlet Witch
accidentally threw into a building
triggering the sokovia accords and the
division between the Avengers in Civil
War like cool now Stark would have a
version of CAP who doesn't hate him
check I think I get where I'm going with
this gradual reality to me suggests a
story that explores other less fragile
ultimate realities one alternate
realities Scarlet Witch with her brother
Quicksilver still alive and her with
full confident use of her powers a
different alternate reality vision who
controls his mind stone rather than
letting it control him in different Sur
alternate realities spider-man oh wait
thirty is one his name is Miles Morales
all of these alternate reality heroes
coming together to form one badass
mashup the way basketball fans have
their fantasy top five like Michael
Jordan from the 8485 season plus LeBron
James from his 2012-2013 season plus
bucks money from space champion that's
really all I know about basketball but
you know comic book nerds deserve our
own dream teams and if you watch Rick
and Morty the equivalent here would be
SEAL team Rick's like none of those
Rick's knew each other at first but they
were each badass Rick's from their own
home realities who came together in the
Citadel of Rick's to form an elite team
of super soldiers
of course the villainous main brick that
we follow pretty easily took them down
but let's just hope that Thanos isn't
too familiar with the multiverse there's
really no way a bro that's wall has time
to read comic books my question for you
is do you think Avengers 4 is more
likely to feature time travel or
alternate realities comment down below
with your thoughts and follow new
rockstars on twitter and instagram at
new rockstars and for the real scoop on
all this stuff just for me follow me on
twitter and
a TA vas there you can get all the
updates from I live Marvel parodies show
infinity fan which guys sold out last
month so we're doing another performance
just for you Friday November 16th 8 p.m.
Acme Theatre in North Hollywood in Los
Angeles ticket info will be available
soon guys it's a super funny and I get
to make all these dark Marvel jokes that
don't get to make here you won't want to
miss it and of course subscribe to new
rockstars this channel for more Avengers
updates and for the occasional visit for
more badass Eric some other realities
yeah we've been to some weird places
here